الى نموذج فريد العائلات السعوديه
الرياضيه قدمته الام نرمين رضا وابنها عبد
الله رضا ضمن دوره الالعاب السعوديه 20 22
والتي تعد اكبر حدث رياضي وطني في تاريخ
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وذلك باعتلائها
منصه تتويج في ختام منافسات السباق
الثلاثي حيث توجت اللاعبه الام بفضيه
السيدات واللاعب الابلزيه الرجال الحساب
الرسمي للجنه الاولمبيه والبرلمبيه
السعوديه
وذلك بمناسبه نجاحهما في تسجيل اسمائهما
في تاريخ السجلات الرياضه السعوديه
من جده تنضم الينا الرياضيه ووالده عبد
الله علي رضا نيرمين رضا
عبد الله علي رضا اهلا بكما نيرمين اهلا
بك عبد الله تحيه لكم مبارك لكم هذا الفوز
في اكبر حدث وطني في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
مرحبا مرحبا جميعا طيب نرمين كيف كان
شغلكم بالتتويج مع بعض كعائله في هذا
الحدث التاريخي في المملكه
مشاركه هذه اللحظه مع عبد الله ااا رغم
انني اعلى منه ما حقق مكان يتمناه بس هذه
دروس احد اهم دروس الرياضه اننا نستسلم
وان شاء الله يعود
ويعني يصل الى الهداف اللي هو كان راسه
طيب عبد الله بينك وبين والدتك ام عبد
الله الكريمه هل كنت اتوقع الفوز ومن كانت
حظوظه اكبر قبل دوري
والله الالعاب والحدث هذا كان حلم اللي
انا ااا
في سنين يعني الماضيه بس الحمد لله ان ااا
مدينه نشارك مو بس نشارك مو بس اللي قال
لك عندي نفسنا نشارك وشارك مع الوالده هذه
يعني جاز انجاز كبيره انت بالفوز اذا
وبدون الفوز كمان الحمد لله الحمد لله
كيف كان شعورك اولا بهذا الفوز
اما اكيد الشعور جميل يعني من وراء يوجهت
وعمل اا بس اكيد يعني
خصوصا في عمري
فكان شعور جميل واكيد كنت يعني اعمل من
وراء همم تحقيقه ولكن الا ما يكون في امم
شك انه هل ممكن
طيب عبد الله كان في صوره كثير جميله
ومعبره انتشرت على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وانت تقبل راس والدتك في كتاب
منافسات سباق ثلاثيه وبعد التتويج اليوم
مع عبد الله ماذا تقول لوالدتك على الهواء
مباشره في صباح العربيه
الوالده قبل الفوز انا وهذا الشيء فرحت
فيها يعني فرحه فرحه كبيره جميله يعني ان
شاء الله اللي انا عندي سنين همم
وشارك فيها بس همم نشارك مع الوالده هذا
الشيء يمكن ما تحصل بعد الالعاب هذه
في في فوز الوالده قبل الفوز يعني طيب
الالعاب الاولمبيه السعوديه لهذه السنه هل
تخيلتي ان انت صاعدين الى منصه تتويج مع
عبد الله ضمن الفائزين همم بالسباقات
الحقيقه انا اؤمن بقدرات
جميعانا
فاعتقد ان اي حد يضع لنفسه هدف ويعمل من
وراء تحت همم ان شاء الله يقدر ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى خلقنا في احسن صوره واعطانا
قدرات هائله
انت يعني هذا الدرس ان شاء الله اكتسبه
الاطفال عنده اتمنى ان اكتسبوا ان يؤمن
بقدراتهم همم
عبد الله كان في اسلوب حياه تبعته العائله
ومن بينهم عبد الله اسلوب حياه رياضي شو
يا عبد الله
لا لا اكيد واحنا صغار بنشارك في
الرياضيات
الكوره التنس وغيرها
والان ثلاثه اربع سنين
رياضه جديده عندنا في المملكه تاسست
الاتحاد خلها بس
تقريبا سنتين فالحمد لله نشوف مستوى
اللاعبين تطورت بشكل سريع وعدد المشاركين
في اللعبه هذه تطوره وكثره ان شاء الله
يعني في السنين القادمه يعني عندنا همم
عند النفس اللي نشارك ابطال العالم ابطال
الخليج ان شاء الله يعني الهدف الهدف من
البطوله هذه ما كان بكل صراحه انجاز نفسيا
بس انه نشجع ال الجيل اللي بعدنا اللي هم
هم الابطال هم اللي يقدروا يشاركون
وينافسون ابطال العالم احنا خلاص
31 32 سنه الوالده ما شاء الله عليها 55
سنه
فيعني الهدف الهدف الكبير ان ان الجيل
اللي جاي بعد يشارك يكون ونافسون الطالب
واحنا ان شاء الله بس نشجعهم
شكرا جزيلا لكما من دبي عبد الله علي هو
ايضا نشكر من جده الرياضيه ووالده عبد
الله مرمي رضا شكرا لكم
شكرا شكرا